mayo de 2020 Mineápolis se convirtió en
el símbolo de la violencia policial en
Estados Unidos tras el asesinato de
George Floyd a manos de un oficial
blanco desde entonces al menos otros
cuatro hombres afroamericanos desarmados
del área de Minneapolis han muerto a
manos de la policía entre ellos Downtown
wright quien fue asesinado a tiros
durante una detención rutinaria en abril
de 2021
y aún así la policía lo perfiló
Aunque en un millón de años Pensé que
algo así no sucedería no somos gángsters
ni hacemos mal a la gente somos gente
decente
no se supone que nos pasará a nosotros
cuando White trató de alejarse de los
oficiales King Potter una veterana de la
fuerza policial le disparó fatalmente la
oficial que afirmó que confundió su arma
con un taser fue declarada culpable de
homicidio involuntario Definitivamente
hay un problema con la forma en que se
entrena la policía la forma en que
funciona todo si mi hijo tuviera cabello
rubio y ojos azules probablemente
todavía estaría vivo hoy
desde 2020 alrededor de un tercio de los
policías de Minneapolis han dejado el
cuerpo el departamento de policía ha
realizado cambios patrullas desarmadas
horarios de trabajo más cortos y un
enfoque en recuperar la confianza de la
comunidad
he tenido la intención de acercarme a
las comunidades Porque muchos de ellos
no nos conocen ellos ven el uniforme Así
que cuando ven el uniforme Piensan en lo
que sucedió en 2020 pero no somos todos
nosotros Nosotros también somos personas
a principios de este año el departamento
de derechos humanos de Minnesota publicó
un informe que mostraba que el
departamento de policía de Minneapolis
Tenía un patrón de discriminación racial
cuando salió eso me molestó dice que
tenemos un patrón de discriminación por
lo que veo aquí y lo que estos oficiales
están haciendo y lo que estoy haciendo
sí está ese incidente tenemos algo de
historia Yo entiendo eso pero
personalmente No creo que seamos
nosotros
ejecutiva ordenando a las agencias
federales encargadas de hacer cumplir la
ley revisar las políticas de uso de la
fuerza con un gran defecto según los
críticos no se aplica las 18.000
agencias estatales y locales del país
surgió de la energía del movimiento
se reunió con la familia de George Floyd
pero aún no ha aprobado una legislación
significativa sobre responsabilidad
policial necesitan que los hombres
negros salgan y voten los hombres negros
diciendo que nosotros necesitamos
justicia económica y necesitamos que la
policía deje de matarnos sino miraremos
en una dirección diferente
a pesar de representar alrededor del 13%
de la población Los afroestadores
representan el 25% de los asesinados por
la policía este año una disparidad que
podría costarle a los demócratas parte
del crucial voto negro